he's been struggling to control
Parliament and even hundreds of
kilometers from Westminster Boris
Johnson wasn't having an easy time of it
Britain's Prime Minister was in Scotland
to announce extra funding for farmers he
hasn't got the election he wants yet but
with photo opportunities like this the
campaign certainly feels like it's
underway Johnson insists he's no
intention of resigning if he doesn't get
Britain out of the EU soon that is not a
hypothesis I am willing to contemplate I
want to ask to get this thing done and
you know I think the people in this
country also do and there's an
opportunity to be so much more positive
about all this earlier at a fish market
he promised again that Britain would
leave the European Union by the 31st of
October opposition parties are
continuing to pile on the pressure
saying they'll vote against his plans to
hold an October the 15th general
election
just days before what could be Britain's
last EU summit Boris Johnson is hoping
that he'll be able to secure the support
of 2/3 of MPs in the Commons to push
through a general election and
mid-october October 15th is the date
that he's proposing but the opposition
just simply aren't going to budge they
don't trust him
and they want to make sure that this
brexit extension is in place before they
agree to anything it's been quite a week
for Prime Minister Johnson sorry a
bigger part on Thursday his own brother
resigns as an MP and Minister saying he
was torn between family loyalty and the
national interest his majority has been
obliterated after he expelled 21 MPs
trying to stop a no-till brexit and a
bill to stop the country crashing out of
the EU is going through Parliament
there's been a small victory for the
government though with the High Court in
London ruling that the decision to
suspend parliament for five weeks is
legal the saying a week in politics is a
long time has never felt more
appropriate Boris Johnson is a man under
pressure to deliver the promises he's
made and keeps on making though may not
be able to keep a general election
seems the
but the electorate is weary of brexit
Emma Haywood al-jazeera
in Westminster